[Music]
shoutouts to the citizens of Joe Mallya
for putting on some awesome questions
and suggestions for us today we have one
from Jessica argh way less I hope I said
that right what do you think about the
hustle culture during this time
specifically the mindset that if you did
not learn something new during this you
were not productive during the stay at
home okay helpful or harmful or just
super aja mom-ish I 100% agree if you if
you didn't use this time to like do
something yeah or work on anything yeah
yeah you're waste of [ __ ] time yeah I
mean are you like not working I agree
with that because some people work
really [ __ ] hard and then yeah this
time came about and now you're just
chilling and you're not like [ __ ]
going in on yourself and you're just on
coast I mean you're still learning how
to chill you're still learning
okay alright if you have a thing that
you as long as you're one of those
people who's like I have a goal if you
did nothing towards your goal during
this then in Colombia yeah especially
when you have all this time away from
work and [ __ ] because I see so many
people like this other side is like I'm
on father if you're posting about
workouts like this is the time for
people's like mental but it's I'm
following you if you're posting workouts
is that what they said no like I'm not
following you if you're like trying to
promote that they're like you're
pressuring women you're pressuring men
into electron alou's wait this is a time
these pressure me this is the perfect
time to pressure me I'm like no like if
you're if there's something you want to
do is like Steve said right you should
be doing you have plenty of time yeah if
you were doing something you're working
hard you're training before this don't
just stop now because of this you know
and if you like all I just say break for
this or something like a lot of people
that I know that do have like mental
health issues this is made it worse
because now that away from scheduled
they're just in by themselves so much
more stuck with that I have a friend
who's a cop and uh she she she was
telling us that like at five o'clock
that's usually the hour that people with
like that they just didn't want to kill
themselves like at that hour like
everyday kill our huh
it's the suicide hour again guys damn
let's get ready just it's just really
yeah here's our I feel it's like it's
your [ __ ] life I'm not gonna judge
you dude do whatever you want with your
life but if you like want more in your
life and then you [ __ ] off during
quarantine and then afterwards you're
like well I didn't want to feel
pressured to do anything and that's why
I'm still here that's your [ __ ] fault
like just stop it just stop it you're me
it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
feeling pressure like if someone wants
to work out during their quarantine
that's them they want to work on their
life if you don't want to work out
during quarantine that's you but you can
also accept that you don't want to work
on your body
laziness a lot of the things I see is
they're putting it out because they
don't want other people to it's like
almost I don't want to see them succeed
when I'm not because and I'm that exact
way where they're putting out like you
don't don't feel pressure to work out
because they don't want to or they can't
yeah yeah they're trying to hold other
people back Nadine you are not being
responsible you have a platform and
showing people that you are working out
during this is making people think that
they should be working on - and they
could endanger them saddle them
this is kind of boring as [ __ ] I hear
out there culture even without this time
is bad
I don't like console yeah you know it's
like you can always sleep later work
hard work hard and I get who they're
talking to
they're talking to people who are
extremely lazy and don't [ __ ] do [ __ ]
and have no purpose but I also think
it's a dangerous way of thinking because
you're constantly working and not and
you're doing it for stupid reasons - for
vanity for money for that private jet or
whatever yeah hustle culture people
always show like jet planes or tropical
beaches like they think that everyone is
motivated by the same thing a lot of
people are ya know demo you can always
tell the demographic okay let's go right
here our grind culture goes grind grind
hashtag run yeah okay
wake up grind that you know what I saw a
dietitian because of the gut health
issues I was having
she said the number one thing I had to
cut out with stress that like the number
one thing that was causing digestive
issues was how much stress I was putting
on myself because I was always just like
like grinding busy busy busy I mean
there is a toxic side to that culture
but what they're what they're speaking
to are a lot of people who don't even
get started yeah but I think that's
where it can become toxic is because
people who are constantly addicted to
hustling yeah I've seen the dark side of
that and so it seems like now it's kind
of cool to be constantly working
entrepreneurship is cool owning
businesses is cool you know learning
money finance all these things used to
be like whack like everyone wanted to be
a [ __ ] rock star but now you want to
be a YouTube entrepreneur or something
else but in this time now it seems like
everyone's showing off how much they're
getting done during quarantine now I
consider myself to being a bit of a
workaholic in a way but also I can't
stop thinking and then the way that I've
managed this in the more healthier way
is doing things that I want to do in a
more mentally rewarding in emotionally
rewarding things like I'll work my ass
off and pick all of the lemons off my
tree and deliver to all of my friends so
I keep busy what I'm doing to get away
then six feet away or I have the mass
campaign and I'm doing good or whatever
like but I can't sit and be bored I
think yeah opposite of that it drives me
crazy I just think you have now oh so
like what was the number one thing of
why people would say they couldn't do
something before and now you have so
much time that you can't do a little bit
every single day to do something if you
feel like it's too much pressure now
imagine when this quarantine is over and
you have to be working full-time again
it's gonna be so much harder later and
it's like that's saying any excuse will
do yeah cuz like really if you're not
motivated you're just not a motivator
you're not gonna do it like and any
excuse will do we all binge watch shows
and do non-productive things it's not
that we don't it's just we don't consume
ourselves with that 24/7 which i think
is what normal most people are doing at
this time is they'll watch all the shows
they wanted to on Netflix they'll play
all the games and then they get to the
point where I already jacked off to all
the porn in the world I don't even know
what else to do anymore I'm so bored and
I don't it's hard for me to relate with
that because I realized I can't be bored
I don't know what that's like saying
like the difference like they're asking
about the difference between hustling
and doing something that's good and
something where it becomes toxic right I
think the moment when it becomes toxic
is when you're doing it just because you
feel like you have to because everybody
else is right towards what you want to
do or you're doing cocaine so you can do
it more like that's my problem with with
hustle culture is that there is this
there is this no binge watching thing or
don't ever [ __ ] relax enjoy yeah
that's my grind culture is the [ __ ]
because in grind culture you can watch
like four hours of a show at night cuz
you're grinding those shows now you're
grinding in it exactly it depends on
what you consider is productive right so
for example very true yeah like some
might some people might say people
lemons in your backyard into your
friends is or isn't productive right
like you should be doing something even
better right and that used to be my
thing is I would never go in my backyard
really and pick the lemons and spend
hours doing this stuff because I would
feel guilty for hours picking lemon but
its mindful days that's what Wednesday's
I was I feel it's a timeless state
length that's what we've been enjoying
gourds yeah yeah you have these stupid
projects that in non quarantine days
will feel guilty for doing yeah i flood
water colored a cup of coffee for four
hours the other day and it felt [ __ ]
great I like looked at my cup of coffee
i water i was like oh my god I'm an
artist this is so amazing I felt so good
and I never would have had time to do
that before here's a step by step that
you should follow for this corner get
your pencils and no pads out guys first
step is wake up and clean your room
because you probably wine or two yeah
you definitely can we edit you out
because I think I look like [ __ ] in ya
three so three get out the pen and paper
that you already have from writing this
down oh this is getting complicated
Oh write out some steps of what you want
to do that will bring you happiness Jack
gonna start okay this is literally just
like
something I'm watching Tiger king and
then going on livestream
oh you because sometimes like if you are
feeling like oh I'm like mentally can't
get myself motivated or like I'm
stagnate or I'm depressed or I'm having
siding or whatever go for a walk I swear
to god dropping about moving your body
or moving it like going for a walk helps
man like weights your movement you just
start wanting to do more movement things
it gives you time to self-reflect kind
of like when you take a shower and you
have all thoughts that's my like that
but then you also have that endorphins
it's like sometimes - yes I just know
what the the walk does for me because I
do walk City runs it helps me onestart
like I gotta get something and then it's
also it brings some routine to my life
yeah you know to where I miss from
before cuz I get why people are even
lazier now we have all this time is
because they're falling into that habit
and they just they're used to being like
okay I know I need to wake up and do
this if I don't go to the grocery store
if I don't go out and do this I won't
have time because at work tonight
I have to feed this person I have to do
whatever I have to do homework but now
it's like since you have none of those
things or a lot of people don't have any
of those things try to get yourself into
a routine mm-hmm yeah create a schedule
do some work time and it's a play time
I've noticed I think what becomes
harmful is when you're doing things
because you want to show off that you
learn something during this time when
you're doing it for others and you feel
obligated to build a new skill or
genuine thing that ya know it should be
something that you always wanted to do
and finally have the time to now and
then go ahead and [ __ ] do it
yeah my house yeah I've been organizing
my house and finally did that [ __ ] yeah
you think that some people maybe just
don't have a running list of things
they've always wanted to do maybe they
just right go to work and they do like
they don't really like think about like
oh if I had the time I would do this
this this and that your mom talks about
that all the time she's like I don't
have like an overarching goal that I'm
like I got to do right right cuz on uh
that's interesting my 90 days to freedom
program we help people build a hundred
goal list of a lifetime goal yeah and so
you constantly have something that you
it's it's big goals small goals whatever
it is you just have something
the list and you think 100 goals are
[ __ ] it's a lot right and it's not built
overnight but it's easy when you can
focus on it every day and that's the
whole concept behind it is like if most
people actually don't have even one goal
you know what really helped me for those
people that are just like trennis you're
stuck there with the pen and paper that
Nadine told you to get out and you're
like I don't know what goals I want
really helped me is instead to visualize
what type of person you want to be in
ten years like what is it what kind of
car does that person drive what kind of
house do they live in what do they do
for work what kind of clothes do they
wear like what is their physical health
like like every little detail of the
type of person that you would want to be
in ten years because 10 years is far
enough away that you can feasibly get
anything you want and then you break it
down into like what are five goals I
could do by you know but in five years
and then you break it down to like well
what's something I can do this year
that'll help me be that person in ten
years so you start incorporating things
into your daily life and like learning
those habits are you know part of the
goals then that I feel like it just gets
you in a certain reverse-engineer dream
and then you make it a reality by doing
the baby steps to get you to that big
yeah
and something really important to add to
that because I think that's super great
is is the state of mind that you're in
in what when you're writing these things
down so if you're like sad and sappy and
like you're just not really feeling it
that shit's not gonna come out and
you're gonna be like I'm stuck like I
don't know what I want you know you got
it you got to make sure that you're like
in a positive state and you're feeling
energized and you're feeling happy and
you could really visualize that nice
masturbate in the middle just get up and
start writing I'm like light a candle
he's like masturbate I do masturbate
though before I light that candle
because you got to relax mm-hmm
sometimes I recommend don't finish get
out oh just so long or horny you're not
going and start writing
yeah but then if I do that by the time I
put my pants on and my pants touch my
dick I finished
don't put your pants back on
gun culture grind
[Music]
[Music]